we are following breaking news in Paris where CBS News has confirmed that R&B singer Chris Brown is being detained on an accusation of rape and alleged drug offenses French police say Brown was detained yesterday after a 24 year old woman filed a complaint Brown's bodyguard and one other unnamed person are also being held at this time investigators have another two days to decide whether to file preliminary charges against Brown or they can let him go the singers publicist at Sony Music have not commented about this Brown has been in repeated legal trouble since pleading guilty back in 2009 to a felony assault on his then-girlfriend Rihanna he completed his probation in that case back in 2015